có họ bắt thường của y băng biên giới chung, cảm ơn chia thái lan, ngày 1 mọi thứ tả mở Malaysia.
Lánh đảo của phòng hai nước đã đặt đồng thuận về mùi ba diện thêm chốt, nhằm duy trì lệnh đường bắn,
chẳng tại sĩnh sau tranh sau những sĩnh biến nghiêm trọng của y tháng bẩy.
Hà bên nhất chỉ trìa chìa chẳng khai nhóm quan sát tạm thời, gồm các tuy viên quan sử tất cả nước ASEAN,
giòn Malaysia đứng đầu, giám sát tình hình ở ca hai biên biên giới, nhưng không được vượt qua sang dơ cua ra.
Để được xem là bất đi đầu tiên để hướng tới về thình lập nhóm quan sát chính thức qua ASEAN,
có phần thế chỉ hoa vai cho chúng sát ngoa ra cho khu vực.
Hòa thuận lên này cũng tại khẳng định cảm ơn không tấn công dân thường.
Không tăng cường bình lực, không xây dân công dìng của sự mởi và tương trọng lột nhân đạo của tảy.
Hà bên đồng thời thúc đầy thế lọc cơ chế liy lạc chực tiến, dưới lực vượng vũ trang,
đề kiểm soát tình hình kìa thời.
Nhưng mới đi phối hòa và xây dự mong pin này đã bởi ra cơ hội hướng tới hòa bên bình vũ,
tại khu bực biên giới, nơi tình là điểm nắm cáo xa cho khó nè cảm ơn chiếc thái lần.